this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you very much mark that's great
thank you so good afternoon everybody
I'm very delighted to be back here
presenting after eight and a half years
I think I've attended my first fund
reading seminar in the department so
it's been a long time and I'm very
grateful
all my advisers and so today I'm gonna
be talking about genomic selection the
global program current status some of
the lessons we've learned and what we
hope to do in the future just an outline
about what I'll be talking today
so genomic selection in the framework of
an applied plan grading program so what
do we do here and how does Simmons
program what are the different stages in
the Senate breeding program where we can
implement genomic selection what have
you tested so far the different
populations the different traits
different nurseries and what are lessons
that we have learned from all this
testing and the future of genomic
selection in the cement globally program
so to begin with I'm just going to give
a very brief introduction to genomic
selection for those of you who are not
very familiar so the first step here the
viju is prediction models training and
evaluation so we have lines which have
both phenotypes and genotypes which
could be an existing panel with
diversity so that is the training
population and we used these lines with
phenotypes and genotypes or train
prediction models and we evaluate the
accuracy so what is a correlation
between the actual and the real trade
performance and that's going to be and
that's what I call is a
pre-implementation phase because V at
current because Scimitar currently in
the pre-implementation phase where we
have not really gone ahead and
implemented genomic selection but we
have been testing for the past several
years and different for genomic
selection for different rates so that's
the pre-implementation phase and in the
next is the lion's Loveman phase where
you actually use the genomic estimated
grading values to make crosses to make
selections and advance generations so
and then after that you can also use yes
for evaluating varieties of testing but
I tease those fast testing so you have
some lines and some environments and
some lines and the other environments
and you can use genomic predictions to
predict the performance and different
environments and the last stage is
commercialization so this is what I
would call as the cycle of genomic
selection implementation and the what
I'm going to be describing today is
about a lot about pre-implementation
phase and evaluation and what we hope to
do in the future about using real gbbs
for selections and making classes and I
would also like to just tell you about
if you will assign the task of
implementing genomic selection and a
large-scale breeding program then these
are some things that you would like to
look at so the first step is identifying
opportunities in the breeding program
that UB can implement yes and the next
step is evaluating predictions for
different stages of the nerve of the
green program different populations
different scenarios and traits and the
third step is what I consider very
important it valuating the relative
advantage of genomic selection over the
current best strategies that could be
phenotypic selection or category based
selections or anything else which is
which is currently in use and then the
fourth stage will be implementing she
has four traits very have very will have
a high relative gain so if there are
trades where she is gonna perform much
better than the current phenotypic a
pedigreed selections we just go ahead
and use GS with those traits and the
last stage is again a very interesting
stage because there are lots of stay
traits very fine she has to be quite
challenging so what do we do with that
is just transforming those challenges
into exploring more about the predict
abilities of those traits so here I am
just showing what we do which she has in
the global rate program why do we have
to go for why do we have to go for GS in
the global program because phenotyping
and selection sometimes can be very
laborious expensive and time-consuming
as well and the picture this year just
features sitting there my first and last
year
PSU and I'm was at Cornell and he came
down here and submit in the selecting
early generations here then that's again
a millions and billions of plans here in
the early generations and the current
breeding cycle time for wheat is about
five to six years so the question is can
be shot in that cycle time and quickly
tell them overnight Easter farmers so by
cycle time I mean here the time taken
from making a cross to that to when you
recycle that particular line as a parent
so that's about five to six years now
and can we use predictions to skip some
years and just quickly advance
generations that's a question we have in
the global program and we've been
testing genomic selection in different
cases to answer this question and I'm
just gonna show you here the the stages
where habitat potential for using GIS
and the global we program so the print
stage here is making parent inspection
here we can use the genomic estimated
breeding values to select parents which
is currently done just using the
phenotype values which sometimes can be
an ineffective predictor of the real
breeding value of parents and the next
stages are as you can see here is GS for
early generation within family
selections so this is a stage where we
would expect genomic selection to have a
very high advantage because you have
lots of sister lines and lots of
Mendelian sampling here your pedigree
can not select the best lines from these
generations and so this is a very ideal
stage for Chia's but the problem we have
here at CIMMYT is that there are about
0.4 million plans of f1 generation two
million in the FSU and as we go down to
the head rose again you still have about
150 lines that are maintained as head
rooms that's still a lot lot of lines
for genotyping considering the logistics
sampling tissues and you just go to
every single time and sample it that's
going to be too huge and then you have
the copy of the cost of genotyping is
ten dollars for example it's going to
cost us several million dollars for just
your typing so we're currently not
testing if genomic selection these
stages and again there's also high
heterozygosity in these generations and
another key thing to consider would be
the cost-benefit ratio so we hear from a
leader here at CIMMYT dr. Ravi that the
cost of line fixation in Mexico is about
five point seven dollars so comparing
that to the genotyping cost of $10 per
sample that's not going to have a very
high cost benefit ratio so we haven't
currently implemented sheis or tested G
as in these early generations the next
stage is ahead on stage or the pre yield
test 6 stage again these are 70,000
handles selected from the previous of
10,000 had loads and we have again this
would give us the cost of $700,000 for
genotyping all these lines so you just
currently use the pedigree and Hydrabad
phenotyping for predictions at this
stage and the next stage is a first
stage field testing which is a very
feasible stage to test genomic selection
because we have more than 9,000 lines
here and we evaluate grain yield and
stem rust in this generation and the
last stage is the second stage review
testing that we have about thousand
lines and we test grain yields and six
environments including optimum
irrigation heat and drought stress
environments and we have data for large
number of other trades as well such as
agronomic traits disease resistance and
the end-use quality so this is a stage
where we are currently these are two
stages are where we're currently testing
in genomic selection and it's part of
the delivering genetic gain and we
project that's managed by Cornell and
the USAID Feed the Future projects a
large panel of more than 7,000 deep
breeding lines from the stage one yield
testing trials have been genotyped from
2013 for seven years now so that's a
huge number of lines genotype and each
of them have more than 94,000 GBS
markers and then so that's a huge data
set for us to evaluate economic
selection and I'm just gonna show you
some of the results that we have just go
ahead what happens when we try to
predict these traits especially in the
lines that are in the stage two of your
testing so these are thousand lines
and the top part of this graph shows the
prediction accuracies within population
so that's five fold just using
cross-validation and the bottom graph
shows us predicting lines across
population so he'll be using about 3000
lines from historic training populations
to predict about thousand lines and
given new set of says stage to yield
trial lies and if we see on the x-axis
and then we have the traits in the
beginning our habits raids have quality
traits so we have your graph flower and
green on traits and then and we have the
grain yields rates of different
environments so we have grain yields and
fiber again it students to irrigations
drought heat stress and violence and
then we have heading maturity septoria
spot lodge stem rust instructor so this
is almost a whole range of trades and
select the submit evaluates in the
second stage of field testing so we have
evaluated she has for all these trades
and as you can see that's just more the
first of the graph here and we can see
most rates have a prediction accuracy
greater than 0.5 which is very good and
the best predictive trade was green
color and that's very very obvious an
expected because it's a very simple
trade very oligogenic trade again if you
look at the bottom part of graph you can
see more straight still have a decent
prediction accuracy comparable to within
population predictions but then you can
see grain yield you can see the dip in
grain years later trace here because
most of them go down 2.2 when you try to
predict across years but still you can
see quality traits are bail predicted
and then stammered us again which has a
predictability of 0.6 is well predicted
so that's our lesson from these
prediction exercises so grain yield is
very challenging to predict across years
but then traits like quality which are
some of the traits like flour protein
and green protein are still complex but
still you can predict them because you
do not have that huge environmental
component for those phrase as much as
greenio does
another question was is this because are
we seeing a prediction accuracies for
many other crows nurseries just because
we have video saying poor markers so
what we did is this interesting
experiment where we had 77,000 markers
which were unfiltered and then we had
filtered for 70 percent 50 percent and
10 percent missing data so we have
fifteen thousand nine thousand and two
thousand markers after we filtered and
then as you can see the trend here which
is very interesting again the most
stringent you are in filtering the
missing data you tend to get markers
that are highly clustered towards the
telomeric ends and there's lots of gaps
in the centromeric and Perry central
mine creatures so we have these
different sets of markers in addition to
few other markets so marker sets so for
example from the 10% missing data as you
can see in this figure I further
filtered them for high pairwise
correlations of point eight point five
and point three resulting in market in a
sense of thousand five hundred and one
hundred and sixty and then we did
genomic predictions using these
different marker sets both within and
across populations and we have the same
a lot of trades on the x-axis and as you
can see from this figure most of the
prediction accuracy is not very
significantly different from each other
except when you go down 260 line markers
so you can see that the green line here
which is above 500 bastards it's still
giving us a decent prediction accuracy
as much as 16,000 markers and just to
mention all these are included markers
so that's agree there's an agreement
with what is observed in most other crop
species as well it doesn't mean that the
more number of markers you have the
better prediction accuracies we get but
for a crop like wheat where there's high
LD about a five hundred to a thousand
markers are still good enough to give
you good prediction accuracies so moving
on and what I was talking about grain
yield genomic selection from grain
yields which I'm currently focusing
highly so let's just move and talk about
what the current yield testing scheme at
CIMMYT is
and how we have tested genomic selection
in these different stages the first
stage of your testing where we have more
than 6,000 lines
it's just evaluated in one ear gated
environment and the second stage of
field testing where we have thousand
lines we evaluate the lines and six
different - that includes drought stress
and heat stress environments this third
stage we only have 280 lines where the
lines I've evaluated in just one drought
one peach Crescent one optimum
environment and then solve these lines
about 500 nights the third stage go to
Asia for evaluation in India Pakistan
and Bangladesh and then we have the
International Year aisle now streets are
about 50 lines and I've distributed
globally to more than a hundred
countries so going on to the accuracies
that we have from these different stages
of your testing so I'm just showing you
here the number of lines in the training
population and the number of lines in
the testing population in these
different stages so the first stage we
have since we have about 9,000 lines for
cross violations we have about 7,000
lines and hundred and 800 lines in the
valley validation population and then
the second stage we have about 870 lines
of training population and 200 in the
validation population and at the third
stage we have 224 lines in the training
population and 56 lines the validation
population so the question here is can
we just test a few of these lines and
predict others or can be minimized
replications within years by using
predicted values and the accuracies we
have as you can see on the right the
first stage we have about point five six
which is a good prediction accuracy and
then for the remaining stages in stage
two we have about 0.5 average and then
stage three we still have lower
prediction accuracy is a point four
because these are now very few lines
which are very highly selected for grain
yield and then as I mentioned at the
beginning are the best part is to
compare prediction accuracies with
baseline prediction activities so across
all these stages we compare genomic
relationship based predictions to
pedigree relationship based predictions
and as we can see in the figure in the
bottom panel across all these different
stages so this is a mean of four
different cycles and you can see genomic
prediction
perform very similar to the pedigree
based prediction accuracies and we also
has the same question so what happens if
we test a few lines and predict others
and now because this question for a
target environments in Asia because
there was a question if we could project
lines in India or Pakistan or not is
there a connection it's just using
dynamic relationships so what I'm
showing you here are the number of lines
and the training population so we have
about 430 lines and about 100 lines of
validation population in this particular
yield trial grown in India Pakistan and
Bangladesh the South Asia Bradby trial
and then we have the elites / angry
trials where we just had 22 lines in the
training and wage and evaluation because
this is just in Australia about 45 lines
with a few checks making it 50 lines and
I very much understand that this is a
very small population it's not very good
for testing genomic predictions but be
just doing it to see what happens when
we use these small nurseries as well and
in the bottom figure what we see here is
the prediction are the prediction
accuracy is an opera : as you can see
and the first few prediction accuracy
are all from Obregon followed by the
South Asia bread wheat run i'll
prediction accuracies and then we have
the accuracies from india and pakistan
and as you can see very clearly here
that
obregón prediction accuracy sees are
usually hired and then in south asia
bread beats trials you see about 0.5
because now you're having a smaller
population size and again when you go
down to the estimates which are the
elites frankly as you see again huge
variability so the standard deviation
there are also very high this is just
across two years and you can see one
year is very bad prediction and other
years it's not predicted well at all so
that's very high standard deviation
across years and the international
nurseries
so the general conclusion so I have
given you a picture of all the yield
testing stages of sinneth so right from
the first three stages at Obregon to the
international stages we
see the same trend that genomic
predictions did not have a high
predictability or pedigree based
predictions so the question is why is
why I'll be not able to predict them
corn and let's look just look at one
more case here when we try to predict
the grain yields of new lines and new
environments so what I've showed you
before I'll just cross validations
within years and environments and here
we have the prediction accuracy is
across years and environments and this
is just considering thousand lines
predicted across years from 3,000 lines
from historic transects and as you can
see the prediction accuracy is from
genomic and pedigree relationships
variable expected genomics will have a
slight increase in pedigree over the
preview relationships across years
because he did not have too many full
sets or half sibs across here's a very
different population so we do have a
slight advantage of using genomic
relationships across years but one thing
to note here is prediction across years
itself the mean is going to be about
point three so you can get a marginal
increase of point O seven to 0.15 but
just again not very high for green
yields and so predictions across years
granules are still very challenging so
this all this made us as a question so
what are the full set family sizes and
cement Co testing stages so in this
figure I'm going to show you the full
family sizes on the x-axis so it's the
family size of one two three and in
stage one the maximum family size AB is
65 so we have 65 full sibs which is the
biggest family in considering three
years of stage one yield trials and then
in stage two the biggest size was 44
sister lines per family in stage three
it went further down 11 full sets per
family stage and South Asia trials only
18 and in the final nursery that submit
distributes globally it's just one two
or three full sets per family so this is
a key consideration here so genomic
predictions will work better than
pedigree when we had a sufficient
million sampling variance but the
nurseries that we are dealing with that
cement there's no scope to outperform
pedigree based collections because
the family sizes are very small and the
next question he also had was how
similar are genomic relationships to
pedigree relationships and this figure
shows us the pedak relationships in a
thousand lines plotted against genomic
relationships and as we can see there
are there's a good trend the
relationships are quite similar but
there are some cases but you will have a
very low petty relationship and a high
genomic relationship and we can see the
range and relationships between these
two matrices so there are some
differences between genomic and petty
relationships but still because of the
small sample sizes genomic predictions
perform as aesthetic reproductions in
our yield testing stages the next
question we had is what about grain
yield predictions and full set families
because this is where we would expect us
to have a very good advantage so as you
can see in this figure here I have taken
ten different full set families from
stage one of your testing and the number
of lines or sister lines and each of
these families is given by n here so you
have about 40 you have 64 lines yep and
then I've also mentioned the accuracy is
a prediction within these full set
families and Stage one of your testing
so as you can see the accuracies and
some families are 0.05 and the
accuracies and another family goes up to
0.5 - so these are full set cranial
predictions and one interesting thing
we've noted here is so on x-axis is what
we have are the scaled correlations
between full sets estimated from their
genetic covariances so this is a
relationships essentially the
relationships among the four sets and
the y axis we have the grain yield to
francis between the full sets and if we
were to have a hypothesis here the
hypothesis is worse the highly related
full sets will have a very small grain
yield difference between them so if you
have a point a relationship then you're
going to have a very small granule
difference and then if you have a very
different if you were very different
from your full set then you're going to
have a large difference in going here so
that was a hypothesis here and it did
well if to some extent we saw a
relationship between the first
and grain yields but what is very
interesting here are these relationships
between point one and point four but you
can see a whole range in the grain yield
between the footsteps but they have a
very similar relationship so a line of
the pointer relationship can have a
grain yield difference of zero to
abrenio difference of two times so
that's very interesting here so maybe
the footsteps are sometimes not highly
related and even if they are related it
doesn't mean that they have very similar
granules that was a lesson that we
learned from doing this analysis and we
also looked at the full sense how
different are they genomically and in
this figure you can see one full set
family and it's just the red and green
just illustrate whole set allele and the
other allele and then you can see in
different chromosome you can see still
in the field trial stage you have two
thousand markers segregating and
genomically they're not very similar so
there it's full sibs even in the stage
of you testing which is f8f nines can
have a lot of similarities and all of
them have been selected to be
phenotypically very similar economically
but then they can be very different
nominally so that's our lesson learnt
from these four sets so we had to test
everything by just not using a breeding
population so we had a separate by
parents on population about a two
hundred full sets from this cross and
then we tested Lee frost Tamra's tribe
has differences and he also looked at
prediction accuracy for these different
[Music]
and accuracy was shown in orange here
ranged between 0.4 and 0.65 and but then
again you can see there's a lot of but
there's a range of differences for
sister lines that might have very
similar relationships among themselves
so this is this seems to be a very
interesting and key consideration when
we try to use genomic selection for
family selections next question we had
was we could use genomic selection and
skip a Europe yield testing you know
so what I'm showing you here are
predictions between stage 1 and stage 2
whether thousand common lines and
between stage one and three where there
are 280 common lines and stages between
stages to entry whether again 280 common
lines and in x-axis we have the
different environments and the red bus
your indicated genetic correlation
across stages the green bar shows the
phenotypic correlation across stages and
the yellow bar shows the prediction
accuracy from a baseline model with just
environment and line effects while the
blue bar shows the prediction accuracy
is from a Chiba Iman and it's very it
was very clear to us that the prediction
activities across years highly depends
of phenotypic correlation across years
no matter how high your genetic
correlation is you still have that
environment effect so the phenotypic
correlation should be giving you a good
picture of the predictability is across
here's and then there was no difference
between just using an environmental by
line model versus using a cheap by Iman
this is just prediction of the same
lines for another year and that's
because so we try to find out so what's
the reason why do we have high why do we
have similar accuracy is using the
baseline model and the J by Iman and in
this figure you can see that the
year-to-year free expect correlations in
Obregon is ranges between point three to
point four seven so some it's just the
year effect which is so huge and then we
tried to look at the variance components
of urine effect and the environment or
the Aryan effect we see that the year
effect is sometimes six times much as a
g-body effect that's wide reba ii models
are useful but then they might not give
us a very high prediction over the
baseline models and the next question we
had is what is happening between these
trials are no break on so we looked at
the trial to trial cranial variation and
for this is for two checks bottle of 100
and katsu and these were evaluated in
three hundred and fifty five trials no
break on the stage one appeal testing
and as you can see the figure the top
panel you have one shake bulldog and
important
we have another check catch you and you
can see two applications and the range
and variation just for these checks can
be up to four tons and please remember
to times between them in the different
trials so great notes in even in
different trials within the same
environment you can have a huge range
just because of the soil factors and
other environmental micro and monumental
conditions and that particular trial so
it's not very feasible to just for the
grain yield using using genomic
predictions and we also answer the
question if this is the case
are we just breeding for the environment
also be also breeding looking at is
there a significant improvement in the
genetics of grain yields across years so
as you can see in this figure we looked
at about 40 different markers which were
associated with grain yield in different
studies and we've looked at the increase
in the number of the his different
favorable alleles for these different
markers across years and if you see from
2014 to the series since cycle 2018-19
you can see there was a very clear
increase in the number of grain years
favourable alleles across years so there
is an increase there there's something
that's increasing genetically but then
most of these markers were associated
with large effect when you low side so
there is a predictable quotient of
perennial which has a large effect and
then there are also very small effect
markers that are not well whose effects
cannot be Beth estimated across the
years and we also profiles are crossing
blocks to see if they have a high
proportion of reindeer favourable
alleles and it seems and this is again
the same forty markers in x-axis and you
can see some of the very best lines the
crossing blocks a green green square
here just shows us as having a favorable
allele for grain yield and it was very
much consistent with what but because
most of the high yielding lines had a
lot of favorable alleles so there is a
very good genetics behind the line
is the crossing clocks as well but still
predictability of granules is not very
simple and that is because maybe because
of this the that we observed here is if
we plot the number of favorable lease
for brainy on the x axis versus the
grain yield on the y axis as you can see
lines that have very few grain yield
alleles tend to have a lower yield and
lines with a lot of cranial alleles tend
to have a higher yield so that's very
clear from this figure but what is
difficult to predict are these mediocre
lines in between where you have a very
average yield but then some of these
lines can also have a huge variation in
grain so this figure is beautifully
showing us that the genetic component
behind granule predictions is strong but
then what is quite unpredictable are
these variations some lines can have
very few cues here and have a very high
yield and some lines can have a lot of
uto and have still have the low mean
yields so that's where we struggle to
predict grain yield and then we also
compared to Don the predictions but
phenotypic selections and then if you
see this figure what I'm showing you
here are the nines which were not
selected if you just select 50% of lines
using both gbbs and phenotypic grain
yield values you can see a lot of lines
were not selected by genomic selection
and finish big selections that's very
good which we can use for discarding the
lines because several lines are just
rejected by using both these methods and
the green dots here show the lines that
are selected by both genomic selection
and phenotypic selection and you can see
out of the nine hundred top lines that
were selected 33% of the lines were
selected by both these methods which is
again good because you're still having a
good correlation between predicted and
observed values and then you can see the
blue dot us here but show the lines of a
selected by phenotypic selection but not
by genomic selection which is about 2/3
of the lines so that's where some
breeders are really hesitant to just use
TVB's because you might be missing 2/3
of the top lines there's a risk there if
you just don't phenotype and just rely
only on genomic breeding values so we
also did the same it's
first embrassed and this is just showing
four different stuff it goes and four
semblance again it's much more nicer
compared to crane use because you can
see about 80 to 85 percent of the lines
been discarded by both genomic selection
and phenotypic selection but again you
only have out of the ten percent top
line selected you have fifty percent of
them selected by genomic selection and
phenotypic selection and a few lines are
still good stem rust had good stem rust
resistance but you still they're not
able to predict them and what we've done
here the last few slides I'll be talking
about is how they have used genomic
selection for quality as I've showed you
the beginning quality is very well
predicted from historic training
populations and what I'm showing you
here the prediction accuracy is obtained
from using historic training populations
to predict the stage one nurseries about
eight thousand lines which wear which
are usually not evaluated for quality
because they have the high cost the cost
of quality validation for one sample is
going to be about sixty one dollars so
usually these nine thousand lines would
not get evaluated for quality so what if
we just use historic training
populations and predict quality and then
you can see the accuracies are very good
so you can see for our graph you still
have a point six accuracy if you try to
scale-up selections to earlier
generations by using genomic predictions
and it's again going to be a huge cost
savings especially if you are you if the
cost of phenotyping is $61 for example
it's gonna be a huge cost savings for
program so there are some cases where
genomic selection is going to be very
useful but grain yield is going to be a
very challenging traders are observation
and one more key thing as readers we
have to remember that breeding is not
about single traits so this figure on
the Left shows us the correlations
between different traits that are
evaluated in the second stage at CIMMYT
so you can see son traits have a very
highly negative correlation with each
other so if you're trying to
simultaneously improve multiple traits
then it's going to be very challenging
for some for predicting some traits
and the last two slides I'm just going
to show what we plan to do on in the
future but but there is I'd be currently
have and what we from and from what
we've learned so in the pattern
selection stage when we have not used
genomic selection so far so we're gonna
be complementing phenotypic selection
with jeebies as well in the current
selection stage and then evaluate some
cheaper marker platforms because as I
mentioned the current cost of genotyping
is about ten dollars so it's not
feasible to implement genomic selection
for millions of lines in these early
generations so what if we try other
cheaper marker platforms for predicting
and the early generations and then as we
are continuing to use pedigree and
height reporting it's typing for ahead
roll stage and then in the yield trial
stage as I mentioned we can scale up
selections to previous generations by
using genomic selection and this is the
last slide I had but I'm gonna show you
what we plan to do a very tentative
proposed breeding scheme for the future
so now we have a very clear impression
that like you're testing say there's
genomic selection might not give us a
very high advantage over the pedigree so
the best thing to do is to do early
rapid generation advancements so as part
of the new advancing sorry accelerating
genetic gain and maize and wheat
projects by the Gates Foundation they're
gonna test this hypothesis but if if we
would see if we could rapidly advance
generations earlier so we have a field
screen house in toluca that's currently
being constructed and so we're gonna be
advancing all these generations in early
generation field screen house and not
putting them out in the field and then
in the exits again go for selecting just
based on genomic estimated breeding
values and not based on yield testing so
if we could do that in the first stage
of your testing and then again this is
going to be based on very few this is a
pilot and it's going to be based on very
few crosses with a higher number of
sister lights per cross and by all of
this we're just gonna try to see if we
could shot in the bidding cycle to four
years versus using five to six years and
with that that's all I had first and
this is a very collaborative work from
Summit and Jesse Poland at Kansas State
and I would also like to thank very
specially thank Mark Sonos Gary Brooks
Tony Coffman all my advisors at Cornell
for teaching me plant breeding that I
could now use in testing all these
things down here at CIMMYT thank you
very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu